[Music]
thank you so much for being here you
look lovely gorgeous and congratulations
i've not uh seen you since you got
married that's fantastic thank you
that's great
i am a married woman now which i mean
i'm i'm sure that you're you know you
can't flirt with me like you did last
time we
got that clear right
i can't flirt like you did last time i
don't think i i don't think in any way i
was flirty with you last time i i i'm
very professional and respectful of
boundaries i think you did and i'm
pretty i'm pretty sure that they have a
clip of that
yeah no it was it was fascinating we
shot the whole movie in africa
pretty
much ready girl this is
embarrassing
um ready kiss please
[Applause]
i told you
you can't do that
it's funny because that is not how i
remember it at all oh really yeah and i
think to be fair you were quite sexually
forward with me no i was not yes i think
you were yeah i'd like to show a clip
let's show that that's how i remember it
now this is fascinating you shot the
entire movie in africa
[Applause]
thank you for doing that bit and uh
thank you for letting me
for letting me shoot it 35 times
no problem it's the greatest moment of
my life